meanwhile more backlash over president
biden's immigration policies as yet
another migrant caravan heading toward
the united states our next guest just
visited the border and is sounding the
alarm on what he's calling a secret and
very organized operation to bring more
and more illegal migrants into the
united states texas congressman lance
gooden joins us right now from dallas
congressman good morning to you
good morning how are things uh they're
okay but i think people are going to be
shocked to hear you've been in contact
with a whistleblower who has shown your
office documents from a non-profit that
essentially are a road map for the
migrants on how to get anywhere in the
country
that's right this whistleblower reached
out to us from san diego
and i couldn't believe what i was
hearing and so i
planned a trip i went last week to san
diego to the southern border and what i
found were non-profits that were running
secretive closed down hotels the
four-point sheraton sea world a windham
a ramada inn those were just three of
the ones that i visited but these
non-government organizations that these
non-profits were housing migrants for
several days i managed to get in the
gates i demanded entry once and was
refused i talked to guard into letting
me in on another occasion and when i was
in there i saw buses pulling up
probably about a hundred migrants over
an hour got off of these buses they were
processed
they were welcomed by people with open
arms that were there in the facility
tested for covet and then they were
given packets and this packet is what i
received from the whistleblower a few
weeks ago and these packets detail
how to go to the airport how to get past
tsa without any identification how to
enroll your children in schools and
assimilate in whatever community you
desire to go in
and it's encouraging
illegal immigration and furthermore we
went to the airport
and talked with some of the tsa people
who said yeah we get these migrants here
they have these very convincing letters
and in some cases they're being led onto
planes before anyone else and in
one case a security officer on the plane
said you know i'm an armed agent i'm
supposed to identify myself to the pilot
before takeoff i'm sometimes getting on
these flights and immigrants with no
identification or on the plane
before uh the agent board so in a case
of having a it's unbelievable and i
could go on and on so i'll let you talk
but in some cases
i i'm curious what non-profit is is
putting these packets out
well there are several but the biggest
defenders in san diego are the catholic
charities and the jewish family
association and you know it's difficult
because someone like myself if i go
criticizing those two organizations i'm
either anti-catholic or anti-semitic but
in these cases they are taking in money
from private individuals they're taking
in money from corporations at t bank of
america wells fargo financial advisors
those are just a few of the companies
nationwide that are contributing these
groups and they're working with the
state of california and plus the federal
government is giving these non-profits
money to
facilitate getting them into the united
states we know that uh i guess the big
question is while while the details when
you see them
are
eye-opening
are they breaking any laws
well i mean i i think they probably
could be the first law is entering the
nation illegally uh but go back to that
airport scenario i gave you imagine no
identification what if there is a
terrorist among them that terrorist is
then sitting on the plane and knows who
the armed federal agent is that has
visited with the pilot and says hey i'm
on board and i'm armed there are so many
opportunities for disaster with this
policy but one of the the big disasters
is the encouragement that's being sent
across the world to come to our southern
border especially california and enter
this nation and you can go anywhere you
want to and we have no record of who's
coming and where they're going it's a
disgrace
lance gooden uh joining us today from
dallas congressman thank you